major Charles Hodges is the US mission
commander for the 353rd special
operations unit for the Air Force he was
part of the rescue operation he joins us
now from Chiang Rai Thailand Maj Hodges
good morning and thank you for all that
you have done in this effort let me ask
you I know you work near the caves
entrance can you describe that final
moment when the boys left the cave the
final moment and the boys left the cave
obviously there's a big sigh of relief
everybody knew that big homerun had been
hit but at the same time there was still
cautious optimism only because we still
had four thai navy seals that were still
back there that we were waiting on then
we knew the mission wasn't over yet when
the last boy came out I understand and
even that was a very precarious
situation that you got those boys out
and those final Navy SEALs just in the
nick of time what was happening well
three of the seals there's four of them
back there three of them made their way
into chamber three and about the same
time we got the word that the pumps that
had been running non-stop shut off for
an unknown reason and the water levels
back in chamber three started rising
which would have cut off our access back
to chambers to one and then out of the
cave and that's an abort criteria for
our guys and so when that water level
started rising everybody started
grabbing their kit and they're ready to
get out thankfully that last seal popped
up at the last moment and everyone who
is able to get out of chamber 3 safely
and make their way out and mission
complete major this was part of an
extraordinary multinational effort can
you explain the camaraderie the
cooperation between teens that were
working on this rescue operation it took
every single one of us putting our heads
together pushing aside any sort of
political or cultural differences and
just doing our best to find a solution
to this so it what I take away from this
is just how much can be accomplished
with teamwork because it was pretty
impressive those entities working
together well said and I know you were
right there at the caves entrance what
did the boys look like when they emerged
what did they say if anything well
understand that to get them out we had
to put them on positive pressure full
face masks
and so we couldn't see their faces they
were in these flexible litters we call
schedules that kind of wrap around them
so they're unable to move there were
multiple rescue personnel that were
carrying them out so I don't I don't
want to give you a non-answer but
there's no ways you could tell the
emotions of the kids but I know they
were absolutely happy to be out of that
cave system nature I'm sure there's some
parents among those who are working on
the rescue operation can you describe to
us the emotional tenor of the work
outside the cave so there's obviously
heightened emotional tensions the whole
entire time that we were there
thankfully the the Thai culture is such
an optimistic culture that it helped to
balance out those emotional lows the
emotional tenor outside the cave was one
of volunteerism there's so many people
that came to help whether that was with
giving setting up food vending stations
or little tiny coffee shops or socks for
the people that had super muddy feet all
of that was provided for free and the
the the environment was just one of
everybody coming together to make this a
success made you had you ever been
trained for anything like this and and
if not how do you come up with a plan
when you're faced with something that's
so particular we're not trained to do
cave dive rescue missions so at the end
of the day you just have to rely on the
training that you're given and how we
approach problems methodically and
logically and try to push away any
emotion and look at it from that lens of
what are the circumstances and what do
we absolutely need to do to make this a
success all right major Charles Hodges
the boys were lucky to have you there
and we're grateful to have you here this
morning thank you thank you sir oh my
gosh can you imagine those details if
there is going to be a movie oh I'm
gonna see it I'm gonna buy two sets of
tickets the world was holding its breath
yes you know what a miraculous outcome
then to learn that it was nearly
scuttled at the end really turned been
very perilous because of this equipment
failure yeah I mean the teamwork is what
amazes me
continues to is they all got together
did this incredibly complicated thing
for which they had no training and
pulled it off despite those amazing
last-minute humanity I love the story
has amazing